brothers and sisters in Islam may Allah
bless you all this video
I'm just responding
to our brother Al may Allah guide him as
I've seen his video and uh Subhan Allah
I couldn't believe it what I was
watching and I'm going to show you the
hypocrisy of this individual the double
standard you know it's unbelievable and
you're going to see it and you're going
to understand it
in I mean everyone knows what happened
to me I got attacked by uh four claiming
to be Muslims but I believe there's a
there's a plan to stop me from giving da
to non-muslims because the enemies of
Islam because mam knows that is well a
long time ago when the police called him
and they told him that that sh is
getting threats some people want to
attack him all right that was like a few
years back all right because they cannot
stop us they've noticed Islam is
spreading they've noticed look we're
trying to make Islam look bad but our
British uh people are accepting Islam
and one of the guys alhamd give us
sincerity and Allah forgive my
shortcomings you know I'm not the best
person to give da but alhamdulillah
people have observed and noticed even
the non-muslims have noticed many people
accepting Islam through this individual
but Allah I'm saying Allah not them okay
so how can we stop this guy so this a
cly attack okay uh and look subh Allah I
used to even now because people are
claiming they were to be Muslims now I'm
doubting them but if they're Muslims
Allah guide them look Subhan Allah the
first two days I was very angry Subhan
Allah even the way I was walking the
street until some brothers you know
contacted me said you need to calm down
cuz I start recording myself walking by
myself on the street and putting online
to show I'm not scared I'm here you
understand but some brothers and sisters
say look you D brother you should not be
behaving like this you have to be
patient advise me and it's true us
became like parano man start St up
people and I think what I'm doing man so
alhamdulillah young Brother since advis
me I took the advice even the advis me
but even I took the advice from both
alhamdulillah because I believe what
they it's true you know I'm not going to
say I know better than you alhamdulillah
anyway our bu our brother Al da may
Allah guide us and guide him instead of
rebuking and refuting the C attack he
was trying to justify it even though I
don't agree with it you know no like
this you know brother I mean even
non-muslims were Li the non-muslims who
are honest they said that was a cowly
attack because you know something even
uh is not the the preacher what they
call it like in I told the story sorry
uh once remember when I started
practicing and I was IM and I got into
fight with one guy and there was
Jamaican uncle there all Jamaican person
was there and he said you're a man of
God man you shouldn't be
fighting and I remember that's the same
mentality back home we have man of God
you should not be fighting of course you
have to defend yourself no doubt but
also you should not attack the man of
God he looks like
and let alone a preacher let alone Russ
him looks like islamically from
islamically perspective From non-islamic
perspective to attack a preacher is is
you're know a man you're just coward
bunch of cowards that's how they even
non Muslim look at it Subhan Allah so Al
instead of rebuking it refuting it
calling it what in reality is which is a
c attack he start justifying it you have
to know the advice I say the advice you
have to be careful what you say no doubt
sometimes speakers call get angry I
agree with that Allah reward you and may
Allah guide you that what you said is
true I'm not going to deny deny that but
to try to justify in it's based upon a
clip that was taken out of
context there is a verse in the Quran
which the enemies of Islam try to
utilize when Allah said kill them
wherever you find them are you going to
say Allah should not say that are you
going to say to to the person who
misunderstood it go back to the context
likewise when the some brothers and
sisters who are honest they contacted me
directly and they say
look we like you we're not but we like
you da we see how you give da to non
Muslims especially when when you see
people accepting Islam through you but
how can you doing people are saying you
mocking Palestinians I said which video
about the Starbucks when I clarified it
to them and I told to go back to the
original video
then all of them without an exception
all of them they said to me
look a few of them said I'm going to go
back change the comment because I made a
bad comment about you and it's true it's
dangerous especially Tik Tok Tik Tok and
how you just take one minute clip and
not just one the whole clip even that
clip is
edited even the clip itself is edited
and who who did it by the way and spread
it
Daniel this person after our discussion
with him in speak corner he became
mentally troubled because we show to the
word he cannot bring Quran Sunnah just
emotional guy rather he became he became
liberal by asking people about voting
fwa you know asking people to to to to
give opinion about big issues which
where Allah clearly explicitly mentioned
the time of peace and world go back to
the scholars and the leaders he was
asking Layman Muslim speakers cor he
didn't like it so he became troubled
mentally troubled and he just lying
against me accusing me many things he
accused us I work for the police when a
brother he didn't even threaten him he
went and he start saying that he's going
to call the police Subhan Allah look how
quick Allah exposed them anyway so my
dear brothers and sisters the issue of
Ali da why I'm going why I said he's he
has double stand and he hypocrite when
he wanted to utilize the video of
brother Abu may Allah
give when he tried to use use
abu's video when he was attacked by one
person one to one he was not making no
excuse for the other person that attacks
Abu he was say maybe Abu said something
maybe Abu attacked them verbally maybe
this and then no he was not he was
condemning it rebuking it without any
hesitation but with us four people
attacking me one person coming from M
praying is walking down W my dear
brothers and sisters it was it was just
deced of Allah the of Allah even the
jacket I was wearing some Long Jacket
big puffy jacket looking like this you
know you can't even move from me Subhan
Allah and it was dark on my side it was
dark the other side was light on the
park side was dark okay and W came said
Salam to me three attacked me from
behind Subhan Allah it was like and he
tried to he tried to justify in it by
saying look what you have to know you
saying everything brother the clip that
used was taken out of
context even the person attacks tried to
claim he was my student he not my
student the brother I've asked I said
anyone knows about the attack one
brother said yeah the guy we know him he
came today he said he told us and we
told him off say what you done he's not
funny he was laughing he said it's not
funny alhamdulillah look and he then he
came to my da table I told him you have
to leave because he's mentally not well
and he's not my students stop lying he's
not my student he's not my
student so anyway look at the hypocrisy
anded one to one he was going crazy
about it why because he will that the
attack will serve his agenda and guess
the cies but attack he's going to
pretend that he cares or he cares I'm
going to say pretend let me take that
back he cares about me and getting
attacked and so on but he was trying to
justify
it when my one is a cowly attack like
even non-muslims online they are saying
it even the people who are not even
practicing Muslims they said as a sh
when he's walking the street he's not
expecting someone to attack him genely
speaking he's not carrying a weapon over
him he gives that where people know him
if you have problem with him come speak
to him if you don't agree with him
Subhan Allah how many people I saw from
speak or people had discussion with
online I never think you know what he's
a sh let me get four people to attack
him why
what I'm going to do that
for guide him Subhan Allah
anyway let me refuse to doubt that clip
was taken out it was taken out of
context that clip uh firstly let me
break down for you what happened exactly
I was in speaker cor now drink in
Starbucks all right and uh that day I
didn't know about uh uh support the
sinist as people claim okay because
until now my dear brother and sisters no
one can bring me proofs clear proofs
like I said they are FR franchised
according to my knowledge even I'm going
to show you how crazy it is you know
like now or before that let me just
carry on because I'm I cut off and
digress so uh I didn't know about the
boycotting uh the day after someone sent
me a message on our Instagram page
platform he said look how did you can
Starbucks when they support the Zionist
so I was like that doesn't make any
sense to me if you believe Starbucks
support the Zionist you are utilizing
Instagram which support the Zionist the
owner so where you utilizing in the
first place the brother Mah he was
honest he understood he true how are you
yeah he knew that that doesn't make any
sense yeah bear in mind my dear brothers
and sisters I personally I believe boy
in he goes back to individuals I don't
follow the opinion you have to go back
to the leaders except if you're on the
Muslim countries you cannot start
propagating it because this something go
back to the leaders but if you're doing
it personally that's up to you so for
example I according to my knowledge Mark
Spencer and mdonalds yes they support
the Zionist all
right I'm not going to buy from them but
now I'm not going to go around accusing
every Muslim brother or sister buying
from mpen or McDonald's to be a Zionist
because they don't follow my way even
though they make Dua for Palestinian
brothers and sisters even they give char
it even they cry they feel sad
no to the justice
of soill when I was on live stream with
brother
FIS we were speaking and to him look I
was in the same video my dear brothers
and sisters I said I believe Starbucks
is franchised meaning that when you buy
from them the money doesn't go to the
zist the person he owns it either is
like our area people say is Muslim the
Pakistan Moran but it's franchised okay
so any Muslim think Ang God we know that
if a brother believe is franchised so we
can accuse him to be Zionist because he
doesn't even accept that supp Zionist to
begin
with for example you cannot call a
Muslim cfir because he he abandons the
prayer if he said to I don't follow the
opinion that I'm cir even though it's a
major sin no doubt about it but I'm
going to start saying you specifically
genu speaking you can
say
but you cannot go to
muhammadd you are C you don't pray and
if you don't if you don't if you don't
believe you are CA then you're enemy of
Allah we have to wa each
other because he doesn't even believe to
begin with he's a cfir he
believes or the Hadith doesn't apply to
him so my dear brothers and sisters look
Subhan Allah
so how dangerous it is
when guide him trying to equivalent the
blood of the Muslims which is more
honorable than a Kaa to a
coffee and he's claiming that I was I
was laughing and people say I was
mocking it I was moing I was laughing
about myself I'm addicted to coffee
Subhan Allah and also I was laughing
about the hypocrisy of some people how
on the earth you telling me to boycott
something which is it's a doubtful
matter it's not clear and you are paying
taxes to America who directly
all everyone agrees that they pay the
zist Army not the people not the the the
the Layman uh yahoodi no the Zionist
Army who kills the Muslims directly and
you still pay
taxes so I was laughing at specific
people they show
hypocrisy how on Earth me personally
defending my brothers and sisters intine
making Dua for them in the mid uh the
things I said these people who from the
who are who who are been influenced by
the ideology they they don't even show
their faces and they will never be able
to say what I said to the zist in
speakers openly show in my face then you
try to lie against me fear Allah and you
know now as say putting together I
believe the attack was a plan from the
enemies of Islam utilize these people
you know I start doubting them now
doubting the Islam why cuz Shi is known
every Friday give da to Muslims and
non-muslims are accepting Islam so why
you not attack shami shami is known to
defend festine sh is known for example
about sh they say my dear brothers and
sisters look I'm not perfect like I said
sometimes maybe I say things out of
anger sometimes sleep of the tongue
sometimes no doubt about it you know so
if a brother contacted me not just
brother a few brothers and sisters told
me how can you say that what's happened
inaz because of the sh I said
may Allah bless you if you show me what
I said that word for word that the
reason that the people of getting killed
because of their will take it
back well I said there was a video long
video I was speaking to our brothers we
speaking what make the Muslims weak what
prevent us from um Victory Mai sh in our
countries I don't understand why no one
cares about our Algeria when I said
Algeria there's a sh in it what every
understood CH doesn't mean every Al is a
mush or whatever happens in Algeria in
because of sh why understood it this way
but how come fistin it's like you care
about the Palestinians more than
algerians okay or you try to utilize
because they in a war and you know
people are emotional try to utilize it
to make me look bad even though people
know I defend Philistine and when I
defend the Philistine I do it for
Allah's sake I don't do because they are
Arabs no because they are Muslim because
Islam Islam is first before
anything so
so I speaking
and so I said that's what I said okay
and uh I never said because like on the
same on the same video I said sometimes
something happened to us either is a
test from Allah or is a punishment or it
could be both how can we deal with it by
going back to for example what happened
to me it could be a punishment Allah but
that doesn't mean those who attacked me
they attacked me out of jealousy when
I'm giving da which stop me from giving
da and but Allah will never stop in as
long I have a life a soul in me and by
Allah until Allah decrees for
me until Allah decre something from me
and I ask her to keep me firm to give me
sincerity so
the so I was speaking in general
sometimes things happen to us maybe why
like how happen to me maybe is a
punishment maybe is a test so the shade
I speak in general people taking it
Taking Clips out of context and try to
make me look bad and I would tell them
look if you're a Muslim then remember
Allah's
statement will stand before
Allah and and Allah mentioned that he
made the D Haram for himself
oppression and he made the Haram upon
ourselves
upon us and and Allah us to not oppress
one another okay so now L against me try
to oppress Me by if you come I'm in
speakest corner I'm giving everyone
knows me ald I don't hide I don't laugh
I'm not behind screen no one can see me
everyone knows me alhamdulillah and even
non Muslims even Shia when they see me
Shia are so many times she four of them
they come and try to speak to me and
they say sh you very like relaxing here
man you know I said because speak cor
makes you angry like when I speak about
I'm not if I see sh person I'm going to
fight no I want for him he wants for me
let's speak let's have discussion Subhan
Allah
so the uh to the other thing as well
about look how they lie Shi said about
they should not fight should the
Quran where I say that where I said they
should not fight clearly I said they
should fight yeah
clearly in many videos I said if now
enemies attack us and we are mixed cies
sufis now the enem is attacking us we
have to fight defend ourselves we're say
wait wait are you are you s defend
ourselves we have to defend our families
ourselves mentioned that it's
called but if we don't have a power
Quran please anyone disagree with me
what I'm say if we don't have a power we
ability and we able to uh uh uh avoid
the fight and the killing we do it until
we get stronger we come back this upon
the quannah teaching if you with me then
let's let's discuss it come to on Friday
or speak Sunday discuss it in a
respectful way in a good
manner that's what I said I said about
the people that have to defend
themselves mentioned that who am I to
Give opinions to begin with whatever I
say what said so stop lying against me
saying said if some attack you read the
about
normalization
said peace treaty if it's going to
benefit the the Muslims I the Muslims in
phe that's what based upon the Quran
andah yeah you have problem with me
ornah alhamdulillah that doesn't mean
I'm perfect whatever I is truth I I make
mistakes but I try my best always to go
back to Quran and do the so my to
conclude my dear brothers and sisters
and break it back to Point Break It Down
break it down to points firstly Brother
Ali may Allah guide you and fear
Allah in that video you made about me
you're are very uh uh you are unfair
unjust dealing with my situation based
upon how you dealt with abu's attack you
should clearly call it cloudly attack
there's no justification for it
four of them never came to me and told
me going to fight they to deceive
me the third thing is stop utilizing the
clip that is been made by people who
have hatred against me trying to make me
look bad and that clip was taken out of
context alhamdulillah how can I mock my
dear brothers and sisters in festine or
any Muslim country how especially if
they're going through
hardship anyone does that you have to
doubt his IM so my de and to to mention
other point my dear brothers and sisters
be aware of clips that people are
spreading against me on Tik Tok and
other platform social media platforms if
you want to speak to me directly my page
is not my personal one uh that's da and
I'm on Tik Tok sometime I go live I
welcome people except if people are
stubborn just want to waste my time I
have to stop it may Allah guide us may
Allah give us sincerity may Allah Aid
our brothers and sisters in Gaza and may
Allah give them Victory and may Allah
accept those who have passed away as the
martyrs and one thing I want to mention
how can I believe that people pH will I
make du as as a and and ask Allah to
have mercy upon them but like they
said what happened to the people's
intellect however let me finish the
topic we continue to call and refuting
Atheism Christianity ISM Hinduism
Buddhism Sikhism and kism and shiism
andm every ISM and our criteria is Quran
and me refuting the other groups doesn't
mean if I see one of them if I see Hindu
or sik or Jew I'm going to kill him no
intellectual reputation alhamdulillah
now if someone attack me my best to
defend myself alhamdulillah even by the
British law you allow to do it may Allah
bless you my dear brothers and sisters
may Allah give us
sincerity what about
C